begins with the talk by any news we've
done some very exciting work connecting
cryptography and meta complexity and you
can see the title right there
thank you Eric for introducing me and
thanks everyone for coming at this
Friday morning yeah so I'm very happy to
be here to talk about my work on
cryptography from sub-linear time
average case partners of time bounded
common welcome plastic and this is John
work with Professor Rafa pass and Corner
attack and Tel Aviv University
um yeah so today uh let us start by
looking at well some basic properties of
meta capacity problems so let's see to
be like a complexity measure uh it can
be circumcised it can be come over
capacity and here we're interested in
well the minimal C capacity Problem
prematurized by a threshold s so this is
just a language of like every string
with seek complexity at most s of length
of x
and today our basic question here
um is well does the hardness of mCP and
over 4 implies the hardness of mCP and
over 2. well if you look at it well this
should be like sound kind of like a
basic questions about meta complex
problems and they as far as I know okay
we really don't have much to say about
this and I'm a well this is kind of
surprising right and well think about it
this is just saying hey if I have like
an attacker or an algorithm for mCP over
two uh there should be nothing special
about about this like MR2 right and it
should like also somehow make it work
for like threshold over four
and we can even be like more ambitious
and ask well
is like the heart is mCP with threshold
Pollock and if it's hard for say like
linear time if this is equivalent to
well mCP but with a big threshold MR2
and being hard four times the
sub-eximate time
well so like how to interpret this
question this is basically saying that
well if we look at Poly log n then we
know the Brute Force attacker or like
Brute Force algorithm rather say in time
like due to the poly login
and this is saying if we can improve
this Brute Force attacker to say like
linear time and we can we should be also
able to improve this Brute Force
attacker for like a threshold n over two
kind of you kind of keep the same ratio
and searched from like a 2 to the N over
two to say stop exponential time
yes
yeah I'm very happy to hear about the
answers too because as far as I know
like for most uh like we don't know uh
downstairs uh if anyone knows like
something just please let me know and
yeah great so um
yeah so let me mention like some results
on this uh yeah uh highlight and Raku
they had a very beautiful result saying
that we have like an oracle world I wish
MCT so now C is like minimum circular
size and mcspl over four is is hard but
mcsp and word two is easy
well so this kind of is well like our
intuition before that is like there's
nothing special about like nr2 uh it
just it's not true in a right price of
the world well like you can kind of kind
of see the reason behind this but well
it should be it's you well if there's no
Oracle at all right
and so today uh our main theorem says
well this yes for uh both the questions
if we look at like a proper notion of a
KT composite and the appropriate notion
of average case hardness
um so we'll show that well if this
average case harness of mktp with
threshold M14 is essentially equivalent
to average case partners of mktp with
threshold and word two
and we also show that well mktp with
thresholds just poly login is hard for
like linear time or even just doubling
your time is equivalent to mktp being
average gets hard for stop exponential
time
and yeah very very curiously like our
proof goes through the notion of where
it functions so let us introduce the
notion of my function
and yeah so this is really like a genius
notion and this was proposed by
different hammer in 76 and so a function
is a YY if say it's easy to compute so
it should be able to be computed in
polynomial time and it's also hard to
reverse so no PPT machine can invert
this function
so we have a random input X it's easy to
compute f of x but it's hard to get back
to X
and a famous example of when function
candidate is basically this
multiplication function where you take
these two like inputs and you use this
input to find like two large random
Prime p and Q is simply output P times Q
and if if you build it like Factory is
hard then this function is actually one
way and let us recall the formal
definition a bit so for any function f
we say let's say it's one way if any PPT
attacker a given a random input X of M
bits and let y equal f of x and the
probability that the attacker a on input
y finds a pre-image of f of x is at most
a negligible amount
and as we know that the function is
really really important object in
cryptography and is both necessary and
sufficient for a branch of
cryptography tests which we refer to
private key Primitives including well
private key encryption this is where the
Nam prep the key is from and also a
student generator and also digital
signature or this is how Pro like
blockchain kind of builds build upon
this and we have like authentication
scheme so we cannot be like Integrity of
the whole internet well also like it's
viewed on this and we have student
function communism schemes toys tossing
scheme and well let's this list goes on
although uh public key Primitives are
multiply the computation and obfuscation
are not included in this list but we
have like so many things here so yeah
when where the Royal function exists is
the most important problem in
cryptography
and very recently a result by Rafa and I
um so they show that where functions is
basically exists if and only if
um our favorites a meta comparison
problem mkzp with thresholds and
Microsoft login is mildly hot on average
so here as we introduced before this
mktps is just well and every language
with every string with uh KT capacity
Atmos as of less of x
and today we're going to ask yeah what
happens if the threshold change
um well before we jump into this
classroom uh please forgive me and bear
with me and let me introduce the notion
of time-bounded capacity that we rely on
and I really want to do this because uh
um today we're going to rely on like a
local compression of ktc uh which we
will see soon
so here we are given like a choose table
X of a Boolean function and we ask what
is the size of the smallest program that
computes the two table X
well we know if it's like a circle size
the notion of programming circuit size
then it's going to be the minimal Circle
size problem and if the no shower
program is like time bounded to a
machines we get a t-time boundary
Commodore capacity problem and I want to
mention here while there are a lot of
ways to Define two time boundary
Commodore capacity and today we're going
to look at this local compression
version uh which I will introduce like
very soon
um so again we'll add KT of X denote the
length of the shortest program Pi such
as Pi computes the true stable X within
time of the time T of length of Pi so I
will be highlighting this Tuesday both
thing so what does it mean uh like more
formally let's fix the universal Turing
version U and we're looking for the
length of the shortest program such that
okay give like for any index I from 1 to
n we hope this program Pi like our input
this index should like outputs the ice
bits of X are within a certain time T of
length of Pi and when being stimulated
on the universal dream machine
um so this is really like similar to uh
Islanders K-C capture T notion but here
which is the running time bound of the
program just once contributes to into
the comparison measure so the running
time bound is fixed but it's kind of
like a mcsp style definition
and as mentioned before We'll add mktp s
is just a just this language like every
string with a KT capacity below the
threshold
and yeah so let us look at the the
calculator ratio again we show that when
function exists if and only if a mkdp
with threshold miso of Logan is not
doing harder average and this mildly hot
on average and we will see this notion
very soon but say so let's first ask
what happens if the threshold is like
much smaller than n
yeah it does average case hardness of
say mktp with thresholds poly lock and
implied wire functions
or like is mktp with threshold minus of
login adding harder than mktp with
threshold poly login on average
and our main theorem exactly answers
this question and we show that uh under
like a a Pros appropriate notion of
average against hardness uh which will
introduced very soon so first the the
existence of sub-exponential insecure
wave function is equivalent to mild
average case hardness of amcadesp with
threshold or poly login with respect to
just sublinear time algorithms
10 seconds it's quite a polynomial time
to cure a function its existence is
equivalent to mild average case hardness
with uh of mkhtp but not like a little
bit larger threshold uh due to the uh of
square roots login
is with respect to sublinear time
algorithms
and yeah so we have well like a
subconscious sub expansion of security
and also across the point over time uh
security but this hardness assumption is
just like sublinear
um like as you can see this like
threshold kind of uh switch
so well the first uh at first uh gives
like a great news for uh to cryptography
so uh we showed that proving the
existence of a sub exponential secure
function and this is the equivalency of
proving like a sub linear average case
lower bounds just for this mkcp with
thresholds poly login
and wow this is great because we know
like for some like probably like other
function there there are some functions
that we can prove like a unconditionally
say linear average case lower bound
against it uh uh for for it and we can
actually show that yeah for this
particular mp mkzp uh we can do
something unconditionally that's like
kind of very close to what we need
um so we showed that and there are like
unconditional lower bounds so first uh
mkzp with thresholds poly login well we
can show it's the worst case hard for
establane near time algorithms and of
course this like lower bound fast shots
in what this is just a worst case lower
bound but we need like an average case
version and we can show that when the
threshold is like large is like Mis
login then we can show it's like
unconditionally mild mildly hot on
average for deterministic time like T
Over N cubed
and like this results kind of you know
if you can uh expand improve its uh to
get like hardness for like all
polynomials and algorithms then this
actually gives us a wire functions
within this
is
n minus slogan threshold but is the
difference
polynomial time security with n minus
log n yes professional yeah
it's comparable to those two bullets you
have
uh
yes so basically these results can be
extended to like any of this level but
if you have like a sub extensional type
secure my function uh you guess I get
mkcp with threshold and MSL plugin is
mildly how average for like with respect
to some extential time attackers and if
it's like possible there was a Quran
function like this is equivalent to uh
mktp with threshold MSR plugin it's like
a cross-employment type part so maybe
the question was can you rephrase this
in terms of something for subdinary or
time algorithms uh
footstep inside algorithms
uh sorry I don't understand the question
well here you're talking about with
respect to sublinear time algorithms
right one and two yeah but on the
previous slide
uh this I got this house like uh for
like polynomial science arguments but I
don't think
uh this has like a version for
submitting the dialogue
yeah I'd say yeah we should think of
like my functions and uh yes but like
about like polynomial harness uh it's
kind of the same foreign
[Music]
for less for some linear time algorithms
just because like
if there's a patch of all zeros
that's gonna cause you to be able to
compress on the part you didn't look at
um
uh that's going to change the
the the answer
yeah thank you Russell and yeah we also
mentioned that we already have like a
unconscious lower bangers like even
better than just a linear time we can
show like a threshold a nice login it's
unconditionally not everything is hard
for like a determinative time uh T over
in Cube uh yes really if T is like a
into the five so you get like a hardness
against like n Square time algorithms
yes
yeah thanks for the question
okay uh let me move on so yeah back to
this uh uh threshold question and so
yeah as we can see here like a yeah in
average case and this like threshold as
for this mktps problem it really
captures this quantitative hardness of
the wire functions we get well assume is
like this is subtly in your heart and or
it's or like this web function is kind
of as we mentioned more or less uh
equivalent to mkhtp with threshold and
myself vlogger so it kind of shows that
yes like the if the special is like
smaller and the easier the problem mktp
uh as well be and we kind of show that
say yeah so if you can improve like the
attacker for like mkzp probably log in
to like stop playing your time you can
also improve the attacker for like a
mktp with thresholds Ms or flocking to
sub accidental time so uh like the
sentence I'm phrasing this is probably
like an incredible this kind of Brute
Force the attacker run time ratio like
we're a big like a cubed in some sense
like stays the same like even if if you
have like improved like attacker for one
you have like an invert improved
attacker for the other ones
and yeah does this make sense like any
questions
okay like finally as we mentioned as I
promised uh let us let I introduce like
the average case notion hardness notion
that we rely on
so the observation check here is mktp
with threshold as this is a really a
sports language and the number of
instances in this language is roughly
two to the S of n
well this is like a trouble in some
sense if you think about average case
hardness because when the threshold is
like n over two then like this
outputting no heuristic way success with
very like amazingly high probability
so it's like trivially easy on average
so we really need like we can't need to
like fix this notion of bits to make
this average case heartless of this
problem to make sense
so now like our notion here we require
like hardness conditions on both yes
instances and no instances
so let me introduce the notion of a
heuristic star and we say that Ash is
the Hiroshi star if Ash succeeds with
very high probability one is a mu of n
star refraction of yes instances and
also succeeds will very helpful ability
when you conditions are no instances
and where and star is chosen to be the
logarithm of number of instances in the
language
uh so first of all I want to mention
that yeah so there's no like trivial QRC
star for mktks because this output is
now heuristic will just like deal badly
on yes instances so it's like no longer
a heuristic star and let me explain like
why I pick we pick and start to be the
logarithm of a number of instances so
let's say if we have like a dance
language and if we look we look at input
length n it's roughly like the logarithm
of number of instances in like a dance
language and we can kind of want to like
keep the same the same if we talk about
like sports languages so we'll just pick
and start to be the logarithm of a
number of statement in the languages in
the language
and finally let us mentioned like what
does we mean by like average case star
hardness so we say that mktps which is
like a mildly average case mildly hotter
average star well basically uh there's
no like a a heuristic star that's
success that succeeds with very high
probability
uh so more formally there's like some
polynomial P such as this is probably
mkzp uh with special ads and does not
have one over P heuristic star uh with
respect to infancy over many uh infancy
many influence
and so any questions uh obviously yes
okay repeat is there a reason why you
chose this metric not to be like
preserved by complementing the language
like does that to present any issues or
anything
um I guess oh the question is like why
this like n star well it will take the
compliments uh like of the language then
the NSTAR jumps to like something big if
that's the question uh I guess we just
want to look at like whichever is
smaller so if like you are really really
intense then we look at we should look
at well the fraction of uh we should
look at the number of noises and yeah
and so like I don't think that's like a
really
uh yeah it should be in some sense like
a similar shape or
yes
uh yeah thanks for the question and uh
so uh yeah so let us introduce our math
theorem like a full body uh so we say
let's say for any like Nice Class of
functions F by nice we mean like first
each of the function in the class is
strictly increasing and second like each
function in the class is like a closed
under polynomial composition uh it's
basically you when you compose it with
polynomials it's still in the family and
note here that there is a family of
exponential functions like two to z c
and this class unfortunately is not nice
so we're talking about like a superpower
functions all the way to sub extensional
functions and we let F be such a class
and we show that say the following are
equivalent uh so first there's something
uh this like some function T in the
class such as T Hardware function exists
and second uh mktp with like an inverse
say with like the inverse function of T
being threshold this is mildly horror I
will start with respect to just
sublinear time algorithms and thirds
like this mkhp uh problem with
thresholds like very large and over two
is mildly average star with respect to
two time attackers
so if you take say F to be the family of
a quasi polynomial type of cross
polynomial functions you get like the
inverse T is basically this 2 to the
power of all square roots log n and so
you get say our currently run and if you
take F to be sub exponential functions
and this uh T inverse is going to be
like poly log and you get a coral issue
yes
okay
um so let us mention some relative work
here and yeah there is like a beautiful
line of work focusing on hardness
magnification uh in which they show like
a very weak lower bounds implies
breakthrough separations in complexity
Theory and the way they're usually
proven approve this is by well
compressing like a instance in a very
Sports language into another much
shorter instance probably like another
language and here we show like a
hardness magnification magnification
result for one functions
and there's also like a Elegance line of
work a fine Grant complexity uh in which
they show that fine very lower bounds
imply fine-grained wire functions and
our result here like we show sublinear
time lower bounds is equivalent to Super
polynomial heart Square functions
so let us briefly sketch uh our proof So
today we're going to show like the
equivalence between one and the two
basically y functions and the sub linear
time mild average case hardness for mkcp
and the bullets two and bullet 3 these
equivalence kind of follows from the
same type of arguments and we refer you
to the paper
so and today we're going to kind of show
these two theories and let's look at it
through one uh we want to show hey if
I'm mktps is mildly hot Irish star with
respect to just stop playing your time
algorithms and then see how function
exists and for simply still here we just
take F to be about the class of
subximation time functions and we just
so now here like as basically inverse of
f is basically polynomial poly login
so we're going to show that mktp poly
log n if is mildly how the average star
with respect to just stopping your time
attackers imply the exists of the
existence of a sub exponential secure y
function
and so as always uh by yoast harness a
amplification Lemma it suffices to
construct a weak T Hardware function so
a weak tier Hardware function is just
like a mouse a hotter average version of
wire function uh where it's it says that
say no attacker no tear time attacker so
here like no stop exponential time
attacker can invert the function f with
probability one minus one over P of n so
it can invert it like on like a large
fraction but just no no more than one
one minus one or P of n for some
polynomial p
so let us construct a weak wire function
and I will let T be this like polynomial
from our mktp problem uh this is running
time bounce and our one function
construction F Well it's basically we'll
use the inputs like uh to Peak like a
random lens of L that is Atmos n and
pick a random lens L program so this is
a long input we kind of look at the
first log n Bits And this tells you like
a random length of at most n and you
pick like a random program of the
samplers
and now what we want to do we want to
kind of compute the choose table of this
l-bit program we get so like how to
compute the truth table we yeah we're
just like a universe all the I from 1 to
2m
so note that this program is at most end
but we're going to Output like a two
table of two M bits so on each like
index I we just like fits I to the
program high and we get the output bits
uh within like certain time bounds and
we get for each eye we get like a single
bits y i and finally we just kind of
kind of like output the whole thing y1
all the way to y2m
so this is our wire function
Construction
and we're going to show it's like a sub
exponential secure uh we equivalent
function so assume for contradiction and
we're going to get like a sub action
show time attacker that's inverse f with
high probability
and we're going to show like
um going to construct a sub-linear Time
Hero3 Edge that decides mktps threshold
is like poly log with very high
probability
and this concludes that this language is
like not
um mildly Hollow average and this is a
contradiction
so let's look at say our reduction
so given like a very long string X well
think of X as well like very very low
and we want to decide whether KT of X is
at most poly log n
so given this very long string x uh what
do we do uh we simply like truncate it
so it's just saying hey I just I will
just look at the first two aspects so
let's X Prime denotes like the first
like the the two and two aspects perfect
prefix of this string X
and I'm going to fit X Prime to our web
function inverter and I check whether
this attacker a tells me like a pre like
a uh Katie witness of X Prime that is of
the lens at most s open
so notice here like X Prime is like 2s
and they like the KTV test I'm looking
for is of of lens s
uh so well although like this uh a runs
in some extent of time because it's like
X Prime is so short and we're running it
on X Prime so
um like all the overall running time of
our heuristic is like sampling the time
in length of x where like so you can
think of as it's like play logic and say
yes
so that's where we get this uh sublinear
time heuristic
and now let us show that this heuristic
like actually works
so we want to show first if it's like a
yes instance for mktps then we output
yes with high probability
um so first if K if x is a yes instance
it's basically implies KT of X is
atmosph
and with ultra it implies that this
truncation of the string will also have
KT capacity at most as of n well just
thinking about like the same program
generating the true stable X we also
generated true stable X Prime
so if this is the case and our attacker
a well it should be able to find like a
witness of X Prime
um but well this is like an average case
a reduction so we need to argue that
this succeeds with very high probability
and we have like two problems here so
first this x well X doesn't have the
right distribution as like as as always
because uh X well it's like a uniform
yes it says but here we are like fitting
the truncation to the inverter so
um in the when function experiments is
like has like another distribution
and this problem too is it's truncating
where it's truncation we're doing here
it's like not a well one map and we can
have like a many many yes instances and
it ha and we're having it's like maps to
the same X Prime
and our key Obsession here is well kind
of the more the yes instances that are
mapped to the same string X Prime the
larger the probability that the X Prime
is going to be uh in the wire function
experiments
so say here I have like another X which
truncates to X Prime and I would just
look at what the KT width is of the
string X because it's like an another X
so it's going to be like another Casey
with this and this this case this KT
witness will kind of contribute some
probability to the probability mass of X
Prime because think of like when we're
picking like a random fun like a random
program where kind of hits this witness
and then our function will then output X
Prime so yes like it contributes some
probability Mass to X Prime
and so therefore we can use like a
similar arguments uh in lp20 to show
that this actually works
and any question here
okay great so now yes instances seems
fine and uh let's look at no instance
well if x is no instance then it seems
that we are having trouble because if we
truncated no instance it's probably no
longer to be a no instance because
thinking of something like starts with a
bunch of zeros have having something
very complicated in the end when you
truncate it you get like a bunch of zero
but we only need to deal with a random
noise test so this in some sense happens
with a really small probability and
let's argue a bit that this really have
a small probability so we know things
like mktps is first then the uniform
over noise senses is roughly the uniform
distribution and we know what happens if
your chunk is a uniform distribution
well it gets uniform distribution
so we only need to show that our
inverter a it doesn't have it it's like
I rarely find the KT witness of lens s
of s on input a uniform string of two
alpha lens 2s and by simple country
arguments this is of course the case
which concludes that for like no
instances we kind of uh we will also do
a good job and this is like a heuristic
star for mktp with threshold poly login
foreign
prove the converse Direction uh so we
want to say if there's like a t hard I
want to function then this mktp with
threshold s is mildly how the average
star
so like the uh Central uh tool behind
theorem 2 uh is what we called like a
conditionally secure so it's kind of
stands for conditioner secure and this
EP stands for entropy preserving and uh
is a conditional secure engine
preserving prg with like a sub-linear
strength so it's like a purity that
takes the amp its seats and well we
stretch the seat to like a m plus uh M
plus and to the absolute bits the pseudo
random string
and it's like conditionally secure so
the condition on some events e the
outputs of the prg is indistinguishable
from render and is actually preserving
condition on the same event e it has
like Channel entropy Ms of login
and we're going to show that uh first if
such prg exists Then mktp star mkzp with
threshold by log n is mildly hot average
star
uh well the idea behind this proof is
basically we want to use like this mktv
poly log n heuristic to break this uh
entry preserving prg and but if you look
at it we really want this prg have like
a super huge scratch like rather than
just sub linear because here the
threshold as you just poly log in it's
only going to work between like a poly
login versus like a m so we need to kind
of make this change like really huge and
we do this by combining this with a prf
and uh yeah this is like not like a it's
not very easy and we but we refer you to
the paper for more details yes right
thank you
um yeah the quantifier is basically
there exists say eventually
so uh uh yeah
um so for like every influence yeah we
hope that we we hope there exists the
event e such that's your condition all
these events is like in distinguishable
and also you if you condition the event
is entry preserving so it's a relaxation
yes yes uh yeah so we have this
activity like technical difficulties we
can't get like a real entropy preserving
prg from my functions so we relax the
notion of this and we get a
conditionally secure engine preserving
prg
okay thanks for the question
and yeah so uh now we focus on Lemma 2
which states that we can construct such
like an object for our functions and let
us look at say our Construction
and so first uh record that in LP 20
which gets like a an entropy preserving
the conditional secure entry pressure in
prg with like a logarithmic strength
and the question here is oh why not we
do this like uh you know repeat its
application G of G of G and ideally it
would give us like a sublinear strange
as well
and well the like I okay I would just
say move on because like a request the
issue here is of course this like events
uh you're going to mess up the events if
you do this like a repeat it's a if you
compose yourself because like the seat
you're going to get well it's like very
uh like we are not sure if it's going to
stay in the like in the event or not so
uh this approach just doesn't quite work
and they
so here like we give like a new
construction of a country epprg with
sublinear strength
um so that has says uh look at our
Construction
um so the starting point of our
construction is that we can get the prg
real prg for our functions by you know
by Hero construction but all this prg is
probably like not the entry preserving
but say we will fix that
um so we'll add G to be such a prg like
it's less doubling so it's Maps like an
MP6 to a 2m bits to the random string
and with sample I well as a guest of
degeneracy of this prg X
so we were going to show uh so it is a
case that if this eye is like the
correct forecast of degeneracy and then
conditions on G of X the inputs X or
like the seed X will have mean entropy
so now well have if it has been entropy
hi great we apply hash function as
extractors to kind of extract out what
what was left in X so our first
construction uh takes like a random
guess I and a seed X and a random hash
function
and we output the the hash marks as well
and uh the output The pseudo-render
Strain G of X and we'll output the H1 of
X but truncate the outputs uh bits to
IMAX or vlogger to ensure that this
extractor works
and uh yeah so this is why
um we got like a conditional secure prg
because uh we really recall I to be like
the correct uh degeneracy and if you
look at this well this seems like a kind
of could say enough because well H1 is
like a random hash G of x to the random
string and H1 of X well by therefore
well hash Lemma is like a statistically
close to random and
and also like G of X together with H1 of
X should have enough entropy because
like G of X is like a something roughly
like ms1 and H1 of X you should get like
an entropy so this is kind of engine
preserving as well
and the issue here yeah so uh anyone
tells me what's the issue here
yes great so here we are leaking high
right because uh well like they're going
to have like a different output lens and
so it's not really a student and what
we're going to do uh we kind of apply a
hash function again
um on G of X with this h of x and
there's a new construction takes like a
i and a state X to Hash function H1 and
H2 and we output H1 H2 as they are and
we output the hash of G of X and H1 of X
and and we'll truncate the hash to the
three and over two bits
so like y 3 n 2 over 2 well like
intuitively when like G of x if it's
like a pseudorensis if say it's like a g
of X it's going to be pseudo-random and
in some sense
um so we pick this uh three and over 2
to kind of make sure we have like a
enough like a pseudo Randomness to kind
of to extract out
um and as we can see this thing here
like ash of uh gfx together with H1 of X
should have entropy roughly and myself
login
uh because well no although we like
apply the hash function upon that it
shouldn't hurt it and it's like a it
should be uh entry preserving
uh but the question here is like why is
this studio renza
um because well think think of it like
how are we going to prove this is to
lorenza
um we're going to show that say we have
like a distinguisher d Prime which works
for G Prime but only in conditions on
this correct this I being correct
so we have more codes say like an
attacker D Prime here
and we want to construct like a
distinguisher d from D Prime that kind
of breaks G
so just thinking of like how are you
going to like how we are going to uh uh
break break G we get either G of X or
uniform we want to distinguish it
between these two strings and here we
want to kind of invoke like a d Prime on
something else say we want to like do
this construction uh we compute we want
to compute the G Prime and we we're
going to use D Prime and here the
question is of course like what is the
correct so like I
so bad news like our construction D it
doesn't know which I we are going to use
and I want to mention here like guessing
I like randomly it just doesn't quite
work as a distinguisher can be like
really bad when the gas is incorrect and
say yeah like uh our Central Technical
contribution is to like deal with this
question
um so let me uh end here and so today we
showed that the existence of sub
exponential security function is
equivalent to proving like a application
Slow band with respect to just sublinear
algorithms and second we show that yes
these thresholds like question for mktp
problem yeah if we consider like an
appropriate notion of average case
partners and I also consider this local
compression version of KT yeah it really
is captures like the hardness of the
question of the problem in some sense
like if you move the threshold to be
like a poly log this problem is like
somewhat easy if you push it all the way
to like M over two this should be
something like kind of really hard hard
for like a two to the over two
and also like if you improve like any of
these Brute Force algorithm you kind of
get like improvements automatically for
all other thresholds like accordingly
and technically the notion of a Android
prg with large trench kind of place the
central role in the proof
and we left it open to kind of
characterize the existence of
exponential secure wire function so as
we mentioned before this class of
acceleration function to to the c times
L
um is is like not unfortunately quite
not nice and
we we failed to give a criterization for
like exponential time where functions
and thank you so much for listening and
customers are welcome
[Applause]
foreign
do you have time for some additional
questions
so let's thank him again
[Applause]
we will meet back here at 10 30.